HE WILL NEED TO USE ALL OF HIS
GIFTS HERE TONIGHT AGAINST AND .
OFF THE SHAFT OF THE STICK.
NET.evin: YOU
LOGAN STANLEY SHOT AND FOUND THE
BACK OF THE NET, BUT IT DIDN'T F
THE POST. LOWRY
BURIES THE REBOUND.
2-0.
[air sirens]OWRY WHO HAS BEEN HN
HIS LAST 10 GAMES KNOW W ROBS MK
SCHEIFELE WITH A TERRIFIC NUMBER
55 WHO DOES HAVE THE OPENING
ZONE LAST SHIFT, AND YOU TURN
THE PUCK OVER IN THE NEUTRAL
BLUE JACKETS WENT ON TO SWEEP
THE SERIES.ELE ABOVE THE OPTION.
REINFORCEMENT FROM STASTNY.
JUST GO TO THE NET. IT UP TO CEE
LOOKING FOR CONNOR.
BROKEN UP BY BOGOSIAN.
BACK IN.
F HIS
D-MAN.
HEDMAN.
WALKS IN AND
RIGHT THERE THAT SECOND LAYER.
SIX GOALS O LOOSE.
BRENDEN DILLON CHOPS AT IT.
KEPT IN AT THE LINE BY VICTOR
HEDMAN.
ON FOR
VASILEVSKIY POKED IT AWAY.
ANOTHER SHORT-HANDED TRY BY THEY
BELLEMARE.
MORRISSEY ON
DUBOIS.
HE COLLAPSES DOWN AT THE RIGHT
TIME AND IT-- RINKWIDE.
>> Denni
THE OLD-- HE SKATES IN WITH FUL.
WHEELER JAMS IT OUT TO CENTRE.
SCHEIFELE.
ON FOR MORRIST DO ITGOOD JOB
BOUNCING THE PUCK INTO AN AREA
WHERE THEY CAN GET IH
FOR THE EXTRA ATTACKER.
PAUL STASTNY.Y.
>> Kevin: WELL AGGRE13 LAST YEA.
HAD 17 THE YEAR BEFORE